there's been an explosion on an Iranian
oil tanker off the coast of Jeddah in
Saudi Arabia
that's according to Iranian state
television heavy damage has been caused
to the vessel and oil is spilling into
the Red Sea same Baz Ravi has Monera
from the Iranian capital Tehran what
state media and news outlets are
reporting is that an oil tanker that
belongs to Iran State Oil Company has
suffered some sort of explosion it was
in the waters approximately a hundred
kilometers about 60 miles off the coast
of the court of Jeddah in the red sea
that's what we're hearing at the moment
details are still coming in we don't
know if there were any injuries we don't
know if there was on board or what that
vessel was doing where it was headed
that information is still coming in what
we do know is that this comes in a very
difficult year in the waters of this
region we've seen several flash points
come up not just between Iran and the
United States but Iran and South Arabia
and allies like UAE in may in July of
this year
oil vessels off the coast of the United
Arab Emirates suffered attacks allies of
the United States in the region
including the u.s. the United Arab
Emirates and Saudi Arabia were quick to
blame Iran Iran of course denied it last
month we saw a tax on Aramco's oil
facilities claimed by Yemen's Houthi
fighters but again the blame was pointed
to Iran so certainly oil and oil
facilities oil tankers have become a
major flash point for the conflicts that
are ongoing in the region